محمد ما الذي حدث في الخليل
اهلا الذي حدث في الخليل هو اعتداء من
مجندات اسرائيليات على فلسطينيات في
الخليل اجبرنا النساء على خلع ملابسهن
والمشي عاريات تحت تهديد الكلاب هذه
الحادثه طبعا اثارت غضب الشارع الفلسطيني
الفصائل الرئاسه الفلسطينيه
وباحدثت ضجه كبيره بفعل تحقيق منظمه بيت
سالم الحقوقيه الايطاليه التي اكدت انها
ليست الحادثه الاولى وليست الوحيده ولكن
الجيش الاسرائيلي لا يتعاطى مع هذه
التحقيقات ولا يحاسب جنوده على هذه
الانتهاكات المتكرره بحق الفلسطينيين طبعا
انتشرت بفعل هارس التي نشرت تحقيق بيت
سالم والفلسطينيات اللواتي تجرانا وتحدثنا
عن هذا الانتهاك الذي كما قلنا اثار غضبا
واسعا في الشارع الفلسطيني وربما سيؤدي
الى مزيد من الاحتقان في الضفه الغربيه
حيث تشهد المخيمات اقتحامات وكذلك انطلاق
مجموعه من العمليات ربما ردا ومزيد من
الرد على هذه الانتهاك